it's a slap on the face you know we are
in the midst of a crisis we see it every
day Biden was not coming to see the
reality of the Border he was coming to
see a sanitized a clean El Paso what was
the price that they promised them to be
able to clean this up and make Biden
look good
all right in El Paso Texas that was in
El Paso Texas resident who is furious at
President Biden after his tour of the
Border Town on Sunday locals saying the
president didn't see the full extent of
the crisis there because many of those
migrant camps were torn down just before
he arrived joining us now is Javier
palomares president and CEO of the
United States Hispanic Business Council
Javier thank you very much for coming
back on the program our viewers really
appreciated you the last time you joined
us you're incredibly passionate about
what is happening there you've placed a
lot of urgency on that sir
what did you make of the president's
visit first of all is this going to help
anything
well you know I have to say that I've
been critical of this administration's
handling of that crisis and after months
of myself and others calling for for the
president to come down to the border and
visit the Americans who are suffering
through this crisis he finally came so
credit where credit is due but honestly
a three-hour scripted sanitized visit
that's not a solution that's a photo op
and uh we're calling for a lot more than
this uh you know he uh he he I
understand that that Joe Biden didn't
create this problem it's not his fault
but it is his responsibility really
interesting uh this is the White House
description of the president's new
border policies imposing new
consequences for individuals who attempt
to enter unlawfully expanding legal
Pathways for safe orderly and human
migration they also say The Surge um
research securing surge resources to
secure the Border disrupt criminal
smuggling networks and supporting border
communities will any of this help
you know I I I I think it may help uh
policy is one thing enforcement is
another
um you know this notion of sending
thirty thousand uh migrants back to
Mexico uh is a drop in the bucket uh
it'll help and right now we'll take any
help we can get but it's a drop in the
bucket compared to the 1.5 million who
are already here awaiting processing in
addition to that we've got 600 000
people claiming Asylum that process
alone is is uh is estimated to take up
to four years to clean up what are we
going to do with these people in the
meantime and at the same time that this
is happening our farmers are suffering
last year we lost 10 million tons of
crops that went unharvested because we
couldn't get people to to harvest those
crops for us so we need the president's
attention we need some thoughtful
resolution solution to this something
that's sustainable that'll help the
American people in the American economy
this is Senator James Langford on what
he says the president did not do with
this border visit
he didn't meet with the border patrol
Union or he didn't meet with the
landowners in the area if you didn't get
a chance to be able to meet with
migrants this was a staged event that he
brought in on Sunday to say look I went
right but he's not actually going to try
to say what needs to be fixed sort of
echoing the comments that we've heard
from you just now
um
you've reached out to the White House I
mean are you in communication with the
president and his team at all about
these issues we are to some extent but
the reality of it is you know they want
to listen to the people they want to
listen to and listen I get it Joe Biden
has the toughest job in the world but
let's not forget he asked for this job
we gave him the job and now it's time
for him to do the job this is a
difficult a very you know it's going to
take some thought it's going to take
some leadership he's going to have to
reach across the aisle not a single
Republican was was invited to that visit
where were our two senators in Texas
where were the Texas Republican members
of Congress you know we need a leader
that understands the issue that's
talking to the Americans on the border
the farmers the the doctors the nurses
the the police officers the teachers the
Americans that are suffering through
this crisis they will best inform his
strategy for how to move forward not his
insulated ivy league educated uh you
know circle of six he needs to get
beyond that and talk to Real Americans
about how we move forward Javier I've
only got a couple seconds left
um but I know people are listening to
you very closely
um what you're saying right now and and
by the way the last time you joined us
we certainly didn't ask but you
volunteered that that you voted for
President Biden that you were one of
those that put him in office and you
also said
um at the end of the last interview we
had with you that Democrats are going to
make a republican out of you over this
border crisis has there been any change
there I mean
go ahead sadly there has not I I'm
waiting for Joe Biden to step out of the
Inner Circle to test step out of the
Beltway and deal with the American
people hear from us hear from
Republicans that are on the border that
are suffering through this it can be
done this is his moment he can
illustrate that he's the leader that he
promised he was going to be well
hopefully he reaches out to you because
you were in touch with a lot of people
that are directly affected by this sir
and you're welcome to come back anytime
thank you very much Javier
God bless for having us all right
appreciate it